the nfl inspire change campaign is
coming to a close there is just one more
ad that my producers are going to force
me to look at in the first ad we learned
that it's society's fault that some
people won't pay their mortgage
in the second ad we learned that
committing crimes is a perfectly fine
thing and it's actually the police
officer's fault that that people are
committing crimes and and we learned
that people who are the victims of
crimes overwhelmingly black people by
the way in these in the communities
they're focusing on are actually they're
just the victims of racism because
sometimes cops usually black cops by the
way if we're talking about cities like
new york or other racial minority cops
are going into racial minority
neighborhoods and arresting racial
minority criminals that somehow that's
racist not sure
not quite sure how that works but that's
what we learned that's what the nfl told
us now we've got one more to inspire
change
take it away nfl let me tell you about
where i'm from
where i'm from the digital divide makes
equality nearly impossible when i get a
job i'll make ten thousand dollars less
than white people with the same skills
where i'm from we overcome and soon
there will be many ceos cfos and cto's
that look like me
the nfl and per scholars are providing
training and access to people often
excluded from tech careers because of
education inequality
there's something really hilarious about
nfl players
who make
extraordinarily bloated salaries
complaining about how they on the basis
of their race won't make as much money
as white people
[Music]
around what is the average contract for
a first round draft pick in the nfl
something like nine million dollars i've
done fairly well here in politics and
media with my shows and my books and the
blank book i'm not making nine million
i'm not making nfl money okay but but
i'm a white guy and so i've got all that
privilege and
black people even black nfl players are
complaining that they're not making
enough money that's that's really rich
then they make the claim
that america's such an evil racist
bigoted terrible country that black
people are gonna are gonna make ten
thousand dollars less i suppose per year
than white people for doing the exact
same job with the exact same skills do
you think that's true does anyone really
believe that's true that reminds me of
the other canard that women are only
paid 75 cents on the dollar and do you
know how i know that that is a lie just
like the idea that black people with the
exact same skills and the exact same job
responsibilities make ten thousand
dollars less because if that were true
only women and only black people would
get all the jobs that's true that's
that's how i know that's not true
because i've i've met a lot of business
owners in my life small business owners
sometimes big business owners i've never
found any of them to be evil bigoted
misogynistic racist whatever you want to
call them but let's say that they were
let's say that business owners they hate
women they hate black people they i
don't know they just got
something about them you know what
business owners tend to love most of all
when they're talking about running their
business
money show me the money i don't think
that the most bigoted racist
misogynistic business owner in the world
would hate black people and women
more than he loves profits
business owners just kind of by
definition
like it when their businesses are
profitable so if they could get the
exact same labor with the exact same
skills and the exact same job
for
significantly less money ten thousand
dollars less per year or 75 cents on the
dollar
they would do it but that's not what's
happening and you can't you when you're
making these kinds of comparisons and
you're believing these kinds of
statistics then
i i think you're probably ready to be
sold a bridge
in brooklyn somewhere
more to get to in one second first
though i am sure you know about the ring
video doorbell because i've been telling
you about it for years you know it's
this amazing doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is at your doorstep
whether you're in the house at the
office on the other side of the world
it's amazing did you know that ring
makes an alarm ring alarm is an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring best
of all you can install it yourself it's
so simple even i can do it i'm not
exactly the handiest guy in the world
but you can it's amazing you can get all
the sensors for motion doors and windows
that will work on any house or apartment
just like yours i love it ring gives me
peace of mind whether i'm away from home
and sweet little alisa and the baby are
there or whether we're all away from
home and you're going to protect your
home against not just the bad guys but
sensors that will help prevent your home
from flood freeze and fire too it's
amazing professional monitoring gives
you the ultimate peace of mind it's
super inexpensive by the way you get
award-winning professional monitoring
for less money per year than you
probably pay for a month of the old kind
of services go get the ring alarm go to
ring.com
mike will get a great deal on a ring
alarm home security kit today ring.com
michael
pretty soon all the ceos and all the
ctos are going to be black so that'll
that'll show you okay maybe i don't know
that's that's fine i guess it's
beautiful more power to you i hope
everyone does the best that they can i
hope everyone of all races of all colors
of all sexes can go they really pursue
the good and they achieve that but it's
a hard argument to make that america's
evil and racist and bigoted and no no
one can get ahead and anytime anyone
fails at anything it's the system's
fault because the system is keeping you
down
but also we're about to take over the
system well how i thought the system was
so oppressive that no one can get ahead
that racial minorities and and women are
being kept down they're being kept so
then they can't get but they are they're
about to get over it how
oh because people actually can get ahead
if they work hard and they
study
and they
do the right thing and they avoid
committing crimes
and they avoid doing something that
actually nfl players are more likely
than the general public to do which is
commit violent crimes and get in trouble
and usually the nfl players get off the
hook for it because they're an extremely
privileged group of people who make a
ton of money and they're very well known
celebrities and they're treated
differently than the general public
regardless of their race
maybe that's why maybe my big takeaway i
guess from all of all of these nfl
inspire change commercials is the way
that we talk about privilege and
oppression in this country is maybe a
little bit flipped and if these nfl
players had even one ounce of
self-awareness
they would realize that they are some of
the most privileged people in the entire
world american dream
best country
in the world
making a ton of money to play a game
coddled their entire lives they get put
through school they almost never have to
go to classes in college
because they're there to play football
and they get to play this game and they
get to make a ton of money
and they get to do almost whatever they
want whatever whatever i do what i want
if there were a modicum of
self-awareness but there is not and so
we get more
calls to inspire the change and change
the politics
meanwhile these are the people most
likely to cash in it's a it's a good
racket nice work if you can get it i'm
sorry that i had to sit through those
ads but i'm glad
that i could sit through them so that
that you are not forced to pay very
close attention to this very silly
football league
[Music]
[Music]